when it comes to women choosing to have
sex with people actually don't
understand how important it is to pick a
man based on is this man going to be a
good father you know 81 percent of teen
team pregnancies come from fatherless
homes eight percent of kids on the
street again often fatherless homes if
you're picking a guy who yeah just looks
good and you know gets the juices going
fair enough like your kids might look
good but are they going to be actually
helping you know propagate society or
are they going to be a dutchman society
a lot of times the men that women
complain about come from homes single
single mother homes and it's crazy it
sounds bad like i don't i don't mean to
say that single mums are evil or
anything like that but a lot of the
worst types of men in this world come
from single mothers because you need a
man there to sometimes give a good slap
to the son's face when he's growing up
just uh you know just to humble him make
me think what am i doing in my life what
where am i going where am i trying to
what kind of life am i trying to lead
and so yeah i just think people need to
start thinking about a bit more when
they're picking who to who to go for i
think unfortunately that bad boy image
that's been sold to so many women that
women are attracted to as you said gets
their juices going but those
quote-unquote bad boys which most women
are attracted to aren't necessarily
going to be a good father